So the job of the writer
is not to supply the ideas,
it is to be patient
enough to find the ideas.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
David and Goliath is a
concept we all know--
an arrogant big dude who thinks
he's fighting a sword fight,
and David changed the rules.
But then, I stumbled
across this paper
that had been written by an
Israeli endocrinologist, who
had suggested Goliath
has this really
rare medical
condition which causes
you to lose your eyesight.
Why do giants lose?
Because they can't see.
They're so big and
strong and powerful,
they lose the ability
to kind of properly
appreciate the
world around them.
It's not just a story about
David's courage and greatness.
It's a story about
Goliath's blindness.
You can find gold in
the smallest of details
if you're willing to be patient.
We're going to talk about
suspense, structure, research,
humility, characters,
puzzles, and semi-colons.
One of the mistakes
I think writers make
is they spend a lot
of time thinking
about how to start their stories
and not a lot of time thinking
about how to end them.
Knowing my ending makes the
beginning super easy, right?
It's totally clear what I
have to do and totally clear
what I shouldn't do.
Your first goal is to
be pure and simple,
to write at an
eighth grade level,
but with ideas that are
super sophisticated.
All good nonfiction writing
is about going out and finding
someone else and
inhabiting their world
and representing it to readers.
It is giving us a window into
other people's hearts and souls
and minds.
I'm Malcolm Gladwell, and
this is my master class.
[MUSIC PLAYING]